(echoing clicking)
- The NFT space is forever
and going to be incredible.
- Huge.
- The next 24 months has the potential
to be uncomfortably volatile,
- Yeah.
- with a very high likelihood
of a substantial bubble burst--.
(inspiring music)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(uplifting music)
- Hello, Crypto Art Land.
It's me, Second Realm AKA Eric Rhodes,
And I'm here with my guest,
Gary V, AKA, Gary Vaynerchuk,
(Gary chuckling)
- Yours is much more creative,
as a front-facing name.
Mine was very basic.
(Eric chuckling)
- I've had mine for about 30 years,
but I just started using
it in the art world.
- Love that.
- Yeah, so tell me,
let's get right into it.
I want to hear about your 500 foot view
of the NFT space,
and then give me like a prediction
over the next two years,
where you see things going.
- I overview is that it is inevitable
and will be some--.
To me this is not a technology
or a movement or a social norm
that kind of goes away.
I think there's not a day
that I live on earth
for the rest of my life.
That NFT is not a conversation
that is happening.
Similar to internet, you know,
similar to social networks.
Like, I just don't see...
So like, I view the, you know,
the non-fungible token,
blockchain realities
of the digitalization of assets far beyond
the art and collectibles
that is so easy to understand
in something that's complicated for most.
I think this obviously goes
into every transaction
that's not fungible,
you know, so like, selling a home,
you know, a piece of land,
and many, many, many,
many other transactions.
So, I think it's going to affect
the way people launch music and books.
Like I, myself am rethinking
a very lucrative book
deal on the table for me.
- Yeah.
- Because now,
I have a different path in my head
to what I would do.
- Yeah, this digital ownership for you.
Right through the entire process.
- Correct, then really like,
the ability to sell the NFT
and then the book comes
but then I have a secondary income stream
if people are trading the book collectible
and then the metadata of me saying,
well you're part of my book club
and, you know, and no audio book
but we can do Q and A,
like it just changes everything.
- Yeah, one of the things that I think
that people talk about is,
oh, when it comes to like the collectible,
the digital collectible,
and then the physical,
is there concern as well.
What happens when I get the digital--,
the physical collectible and, you know,
the digital one, you know,
do they have to be together?
And I think of them as like,
remember the old Beckett Magazines
with card inserts.
- Yeah.
- You would keep the cards
you would hold on to them as collectibles.
But the magazine was in and of itself,
its own physical item.
I see the same thing.
- Yeah, and I see similarities.
The way I've been explained
to people is like,
look, that's the most
important part of NFT's
for me is does the human being,
or the human beings behind the project
understand how to actually
build a community.
This is why I feel so confident in it,
Eric, right?
I have spent 15 years
building an actual community
and have been very thoughtful
to not monetize it in a very inefficient,
silly, short-term way.
Same thing's going
to happen with me and with NFTs.
I will launch my own project
and that project will live with me
for the rest of my fucking life.
Not here's a fucking photo of me, buy it,
and I'm going to sleep.
- [Eric] Right.
- All of the metadata will be the project,
not the actual imagery
or the short-term transactional nature.
We'll go into that a little bit later,
let me give you the prediction.
So, macro view is holy shit,
this feels like '95 and 2005,
'95 for me was (Gary rowdily exclaiming)
Oh my God, this Internet,
Worldwide Web, information super highway.
This is forever,
I'm going to put my liquor store on it.
It's going to change my life.
That happened, 2005 for me was,
you know, this MySpace Friendster thing,
this--, the Facebook, you know.
Oh my God, February 2006,
this YouTube thing, wait a minute.
This feels a lot cooler
than message boards and
comments and a blog.
Hey, this is forever.
This is humans communicating
on top of the internet.
Like we do in real life.
This--,
it wasn't even social media at the time
I called it web 2.0, these web 2.0 sites,
they're going to change the world.
Well, here we are 15 years later,
and we're still in the
dawn of Social Networks.
Not even--, you know what I mean?
Like...
- Yes.
- Facebook had a long run, inc.
You know, Tik Tok is a new club
that like, so, oh right.
We will communicate over
the internet, right?
- [Eric] Yeah.
- E-commerce for me in 95 was,
we will shop over the internet.
To me, oh,
we will buy everything in a digital form
over this thing, called a blockchain.
And you know, so, to
me, this is a forever.
Now, the more interesting part
- [Eric] Yes
- in both '95 and 2005
I saw every project
that I could cause I'm that guy,
and, 97% of them failed.
And that was hard.
It was hard to raise capital
and start a meaningful business
on top of these platforms.
NFT's are easy.
The ability after you learn a little bit,
to mint and put on a
marketplace, anything?
I sold a tweet for
$2,000 right now on Cent.
this is real now,
- [Eric] Yeah.
- because I want to
earn and what have you,
and it feels exciting and weird,
and I'm going to work hard to make sure
that person that makes a lot of money
on that tweet, if that becomes a thing.
But, what I'm petrified of, Eric,
is, I'm not as educated on the ICO crash
that a lot of people
in this space have gone through,
because I was so deep,
doing something else,
and I watched peripherally
and when I bought Ethereum in 16
and Bitcoin in 14.
I bought them with this in mind,
which is, this feels right, I'm busy,
and don't feel like--,
especially because of finance,
like currency, doesn't speak to me.
I'm like, I don't buy stock.
Like, I don't like money
but I love tchotchkes
and collectibles and IP.
- Yeah.
- So, when I saw all that
I was bullish on Ethereum
because I understood, you
know, Inner Battalion,
big shout out to him,
CTO of LivingSocial,
big Silicon Valley technologist,
venture capitalist.
He broke it down and I
understood the difference.
I was like, oh, okay,
that's interesting about Ethereum
and I understood building
on top of app ecosystem.
I just couldn't--
got it.
So it was like, okay,
I'm going to do this.
I'm not following the defy ICO thing,
like, it felt very scary
to me, the ICO thing.
It ended up being very scary,
but, I mean it's very obvious
what's played out, right?
Which was, a lot of those
coins weren't right,
but the macro thing is right.
I think with NFT's,
a lot more people will be involved.
Every creator, every artist, every--,
look at me, I've doodled my whole life,
and this is going to give me a chance
to kind of play a little bit.
- I've been seeing you
sharing that more on Twitter
- And people are blown away
at how good I am at them.
And I'm like, cause I've
been doing it a lot,
my whole life, like I'm decent at it.
I've never thought of myself as an artist.
No different, to me,
never thinking of myself as a personality,
even though I have the gift of gab
I just thought of myself as a
businessman
- You do?
You have the gift of gab?
- Just a little something.
(Eric laughing)
- So Eric, here's what I would say,
in the macro,
it's one of the biggest technology shifts
and cultural norms of our
lifetime, you and mine,
and the people listening.
In the micro, there will
be a stunning amount
of people that buy things
for investment purpose
that will collapse aggressively.
On the flip side, the same way in March
and April of 2000,
Amazon was the, literally the only stock
I'd ever bought, in
like a five-year period.
Probably April, probably
May or June of 2000,
because what I understood was,
Oh my god, Wall Street thinks
the internet is a fad.
Everything's going to zero.
Amazon's going to win.
Even then I knew it,
and so, I did very well.
I think the same way is
that's what I'm trying to do now.
Which NFT projects,
whether it's people, whether it's punks,
whether it's hashmasks,
whether it's Kiddies,
whether it's, you know,
3lau, you know, like what,
do I believe in nine years,
is still going to matter?
And that's what I spend time on
when I think about the projects.
When I look at the startups
that I inevitably want to invest in,
it's going to be more back
to what I did in 95 and 2005,
which is, you know,
the first three companies I invested in,
in 2006, was Facebook,
Twitter, and Tumblr.
And I feel like I'm going
to be very similar here
where I'm confident in
my first several bets
because I'm doing a lot of homework,
before I make a bet.
- There's two different aspects to this.
There's the collectible sort of,
piece of this where it's feeding...
Sort of feeding your,
inner 12 year old when
you were shilling cards
at the market,
- [Gary] Correct.
All that kinds of stuff.
And then there's the businessman,
who's looking at,
and the investor who's
looking at the companies
in and of themselves.
- And then there's also Gary Vaynerchuk,
the human being, let me explain this.
- Yes, absolutely.
- This piece of art
is from Elise Bartlett.
She worked for barn--,
she worked for me at Vayner, I like her,
her husband worked for, with me at Resi.
She's making a big risk
and going on her own,
This is expensive, by my art standards,
I bought it because I love her.
- Yeah.
- I'm excited
'cause I'm meeting a lot of artists
on Twitter and discords.
I'm excited to be the humanitarian.
That's how I see it.
- Yeah.
- Or the kind person,
like I'm excited to buy art
based on, I like you, the human,
my natural instincts around art
go much more into like what I'm doodling,
which is, I care about the Smurfs
and Punky Brewster,
and Max Headroom and Robocop and TMT.
Like, I like those things
more than like a beautiful, you know.
- Yeah, seventies or eighties,
pop culture groups.
- I'm a pop culture guy,
and so, I want to do that,
which lends, you know,
which is different,
than seeing some beautiful
sketch or like paint.
I don't like Jackson Pollock.
- Yeah, everybody has their own,
their own artistic interests.
- And I remind a lot of
people who are listening.
People are like, trying to force people
to like a certain thing.
It makes me laugh, like why?
- I talked to...
I think of myself as
a coach and a teacher,
I invite a lot of artists
that are new to the space,
come in and talk to me, dm me,
let's, let's talk about this space.
They're in here for a month and are like,
Eric, I'm not getting any sales,
and I'm like, first,
let's think about what are you doing?
Well, I'm just posting links on Twitter.
Like that's--, you're not doing enough.
You're not doing enough.
- You're not doing anything.
- Yeah.
- That's like waking up
in the morning.
- It's--, 100 percent,
If you're hosting a link
of your art,
to an open sea account or whatever
that is literally, like saying,
I've woken up this morning.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Cool, now what?
- A hundred percent, yeah.
- My, big thing is it's
community building.
- Yeah, I talk about connection a lot.
Not, communicating.
- It's the same thing.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly,
it's the same exact thing,
And it's, who is your audience?
Find 20 or 30 people
that are going to talk to you.
Going to be with you and act
and connect with you daily.
That's all you need 20 or 30 people.
- Absolutely right,
and how much do you care
about them, versus caring about you?
Every artist I'm talking to is like,
I want to sell this for 800 bucks.
I'm like, what's in it
for the other person.
- [Eric] Right
- And, and there's two ways, again,
it's art and commerce.
Is this something that you are going to,
like, if you're doing this
for collecting, flipping what--,
you know, again,
and I went through this recently
with sports cards over the last 40 years,
nobody gets to decide what
another human being--,
Like, I love how people are like,
they're trying to be
dictators and communists.
(Eric laughing)
I'm like, I'm like, I'm like,
you're telling me I have
to collect art for the sake
of the art and never sell it.
Who gave you that power?
I have to tell you
to look at this as an investment
where you just like having
a wallet to display.
Who am I?
And I, by the way, I'm going to do both,
but I'm going to do mine.
That's why I brought up the Elise thing.
I'm going to support artists
that I have a huge--,
an actual connection to,
from a human standpoint, not to their art,
because I've never been
affected by art that way,
comma, the art that I'm
incredibly affected by
is character creation.
Like I bought magic the gathering cards
when they first came out.
I like, like, that's what I like.
- Were you into Pokemon too?
Did you buy those cards?
- I was a hair at that point
I'd really started my career
and I was like 100% trying
to build my dad's liquor store,
but my brother AJ's 11 years younger
and when he got like massive strep throat
and like real sick, I
went to the card store.
My dad had bought him a box
of the original Pokemon.
- Oh my god, yes.
- We always talk about that so,
but yes, I understand Pokemon.
I'm obsessed with WWFE.
I understand why Disney works.
I think--,
and then I care about
like funny little ones like the Snorks
or the get along gang,
- I remember the Snorks, yeah.
- or the Wuzzles, like I,
so I think everyone gets to pick.
- Totally, yeah,
And I think that's the great thing
about the NFT space,
is people are gonna find
their own little niche
and their own place
to sell the kind of things
that their people want to sell.
- Eric, I think the biggest responsibility
for people that care, during this era,
is getting everybody to understand,
it's internet 2000, the
NFT space is forever
and going to be incredible.
- Huge.
- The next 24 months has the potential
to be uncomfortably volatile,
with a very high likelihood
of a substantial bubble burst
from a project level.
- Yeah.
- Leaving 92 to 97 percent of things,
worth a lot less than you paid for it.
But leaving 3 to 8 percent
of being probably down a little
or down some, with 17 years from now,
it being through the fuckin' roof.
And that is the,
that to me is the sum-up
of what's going to
happen in the short term.
- I have a 20 year view.
I'm in this space as a creator,
as an artist for 20 years,
I'm going to ride the bumbles
- Yeah and for me,
Eric, no joke and not kidding,
I am in this space
for the rest of my life on all angles
as an investor of platforms,
the shovels and the picks.
As a collector, flipper, of the art
and as a creator.
- Yeah, a new avenue for you.
Well, not really, but artistically...
- No, no, a real one.
And if anybody really follows me
I've talked for years
about buying nostalgic
brands, cause I love IP.
- Yeah.
- And if anybody's listened to me,
I talk a lot about character creation
and things of that nature.
I had a cartoon called Little V
that I get an episode
of, I love this shit.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- This is like a dream come true.
- Yeah,
and for me, it's like,
my entire life has been a culmination
of, of, the NFT space.
- Mine too.
- Like everything I've learned,
everything I've become, you know,
my interest in collecting,
my interest in art,
my interest in tech,
you know, it's amazing
- Mine too.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Literally mine too.
- Yeah.
So you, you immigrated to America,
when you were a kid,
you learned to speak English, with your...
watching seventies and
eighties pop culture.
So thinking back, like 12--,
'cause I asked this of all my guests,
12 year old Gary V,
what does he think of Gary V today?
Like what's, what does he think about him?
- He's, he's proud
that he didn't compromise kindness,
with the success that was bestowed on him.
I think the 12 year old me would be proud
that the things that my mom
was putting into my head
at that point that were
religion, kindness, nice warmth,
good, is something that I've not only kept
through all the zigs and zags of my life,
but now in a lot of ways,
what she did for me,
I'm doing at a very high
level, for many others.
- Yeah, I think empathy
is one of the things you talk about a lot,
it's, it's clearly showing
in the way you're approaching this space,
conscious of the fact--.
- Break that down for me,
because that meant the world to me.
I just want to say thank
you for saying that,
because it means so much to me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just want to get
your perspective, like,
what are you, what are you seeing?
- Well, you're taking care, to be mindful
about your weight, as an influencer,
coming into this space,
but you're also, look,
you're bringing value to me
by jumping on my show, right?
I know that and I'm highly aware of that,
very in tune to that, but you are too,
and that's a key aspect of your approach
that I think is so genuine,
and then some people miss on,
because they just see
whale coming in--,
- Correct.
- You know?
And so, like my hope
in bringing you on the
show is to show that side.
I, I always...
my goal for this podcast
is to capture this time
and moment in space.
And then in 20 years,
have a tremendous amount of like,
content that can be turned
into a documentary,
from artist's that were --,
- Smart?
- Nobodies, or somebodies, you know?
- No, it's a hundred
percent gonna' happen.
Like, I just lived it.
I liked was in hotel rooms
with Mark Zuckerberg and Travis.
Like I lived this.
- Exactly, I missed out on all that.
I missed out on all that,
but I see this moment for that.
- And, you can see it.
- Yeah, I see, he's got goosebumps
- Yeah, like, you know, I don't know--,
I know this is audio and video, like...
- Yeah.
- It's a hundred percent going to happen.
The part that hurts to your point,
people don't dig.
Like, do you know what gives me anxiety
that in 17 months or 9 months,
when there's a big burst on the projects.
I'm going to get bombarded with,
fuckin' Gary V, you asshole,
See, you son of a bitch,
snake oil salesman.
I'm like motherfucker,
I've been on podcast after podcast,
tweet after tweet saying
macro yes, micro ben--.
Here's what's going to happen.
- Yeah, they're not fuckin' listening.
- And that's exac--,
that's what it is.
It's, it's like when your band,
when you're--,
when you discovered Nirvana first,
- Yeah.
(Eric chuckling)
- And then they become famous
and you're mad at like, what happened.
- Oh they sold out, or something.
(Eric chuckling)
- And I--,
and by the way, back to empathy, Eric,
let it be known, on this podcast,
because I know it has
an incredible community
of the OGs.
I think that's appropriate.
I understand it.
- Yeah.
- The problem is it's unstoppable.
What is, is going to be, this like...
That's why I love the early days.
Like a lot of my new friends.
That's the other thing, when I tell you,
and I'm jumping around here a little bit.
- [Eric] No, please.
- My favorite part about this
is my new friends.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Our friendship building,
from this moment on
it, my best buds come
from that 2005, 6, 7.
It's those days when you're--,
I mean, let there'll be no confusion.
No matter how hot it is right now
on Twitter, and clubhouse, and discords
and a little bit here and there.
98% of Americans, have no concept of NFTs.
So, I remember in 2007,
being at South by Southwest
and everyone's like,
(Gary annoyingly babbling)
like its, (Gary annoyingly babbling)
I'm like, guys,
nobody has a fucking Twitter account.
There's 300 million Americans,
and at the time it was
like, you know, a million
and the OG, OG, OG's are like,
oh, it's over.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It fucking blows,
here comes the business.
I'm like, I'm like, here comes wh--,
what are you talking about?
- [Eric] Yeah.
And that was like a year before, you know,
Ashton versus CNN to get to a million,
you know, like, or two even.
So, I think, cherish these moments
it won't be 2018 and 19 anymore.
It's just isn't.
- No, I've been,
I've been in this space
for, for two years.
Helping build it from the ground up.
You know, being part of,
I think you call it the dirt, right?
- Yes.
And I love,
And that's amazing,
And those are less--,
what's cool about it
is, it's all documented.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Unlike going to the
first Pearl Jam concert,
you can prove it, you've got the video.
- Provenance, Baby.
- Provenance,
and so, you know,
like, one thing I've
been thinking a lot about
is like, you know, that new site Cent,
where the Jack tweet is going, like,
I want them to have a search function.
Like I want, I'm dying to see the person.
Like, this is why people
don't understand provenance.
I, last night, sleeping, said, oh shit,
I want to see the first time Bitcoin
was said, on Twitter.
What's the first single
tweet, that says Bitcoin?
- [Eric] Yeah.
- And then, of course,
- [Eric] Did you find it?
- I haven't done that yet.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- But like, what I'm hoping is
that between Cent and Twitter,
in their relationship,
if they have a relationship,
if they're going to have a relationship,
seeing that Jack acknowledged them
in such a serious way.
- Yeah.
- Imagine having the ability
to search on one of those two sites,
the first time a word was mentioned.
- Insane.
- [Gary] Insane.
The, I tried to look for
the first time, I was,
it was another keyword,
but the same thing, right?
When was the first time
something, something, was said,
- So anyways, provenance,
- it's kind of difficult
to find, yeah.
- It's, gonna matter,
Like, who is the--,
ready?
Here's some fun stuff.
This is what I say with friends
that have no idea what I'm talking about.
I'm like, do you think it's cool,
to know the first person
that bought the first ticket,
to the first showing, of ET?
Do you think that's cool?
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] And universally
everyone's like, yes.
I'm like, guess what?
That is going to be the world.
- Yeah, exactly.
We're going to be able to see and--,
and, you know, for collectors
and it's going to be who the,
who the wallets that
content has passed through.
- Are you kidding?
It's the greatest thing ever.
I would buy, right now,
a collectible that Randy,
the macho man Savage once held.
- Right?
- [Gary] 100 percent.
- Yes.
- Like I don't...
people don't understand
how social currency works.
It's why you're wearing the beard
that you're wearing right now.
- Totally.
- It's why people buy...
People that don't get NFTs,
I'm like, you have a Gucci bag,
They're like, yeah.
I'm like, that's NFT's,
they're like, what do you mean?
I'm like, why'd you buy that?
- [Eric] Right.
- You're flexing.
You're socially communicating,
and it works both ways.
I love when hipsters--,
I have so many hipster friends.
They're anti-establishment,
(Eric laughing)
I'm like that's your version.
You don't buy a polo.
You buy a vinyl record.
It's all the same game, Eric.
- Well, NFT's are kind
of counter-culture,
anti-establishment, right?
- For now.
- For now,
but they're going to be the...
- It's going to be the
Rolex and the fucking--,
a hundred percent...
You know, and this goes to why I think,
what I'm spending all my time on,
is, is it crypto punks?
Is it bet big on Bitcoin?
Their first block?
Like, is it Kiddies?
Is it, like, like what
really establishes itself
as the OG projects,
that has Christie's, and Sotheby's,
and the billionaire and millionaires
of the future wanting to own,
that's, that's not about the mone--.
People are like...
I love when I tell people, I'm like,
that's not about money,
that's about the clout
of, was I smart enough
to play chess, and figure it out.
- Totally.
From a scarcity perspective.
So let, let me,
let's, let me throw this at you,
- Please.
- you know, card collectors,
we think about the 52 mantles,
the 51 mantles, they're the,
they're the fucking gold
standard in, you know,
or used to be the gold standard in,
you know, the card collecting community,
68 Ryan, right.
You know, these kinds of things,
they're scarce because
they're low production,
and kids used to throw--,
My dad used to mantles in the wheels
of his car and the bike to make the,
the flipping noise, right?
- Correct.
(Eric imitating spoke cards)
- Eighties and nineties,
overproduction of baseball cards,
other collectibles.
What attributes are you looking
for in terms of scarcity
for digital collectibles?
- Well, it's funny, eighties and nineties,
what people always forget, always,
and I couldn't believe how many people
didn't get this part with cards
in the last four years.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Supply doesn't scare me.
Supply scares me when it outpaces demand.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- People are so fixated,
they're like, Gary, I'm going to crush,
it's a one of one, I'm like,
if zero people want it,
you've got a problem.
Got it, Eric, right?
(Eric chuckling)
So like, let's say, right.
- That's so true.
- Right? There's a lot
of blue Snaggletooths,
that were in the Sears cantina set only.
There's just a lot more Star Wars nerds
that want that one than the red one
that was on an empire strikes back card.
Hence, it's worth more.
- [Eric] Right.
- It's not like Star Wars
only made one yak face power...
Like, there's like,
Migos on cards from the
seventies action figures.
Like, you don't need there
to be one in existence or 19 or 57.
This is my point with
Michael Jordan and Charizard.
Michael Jordan rookie and Charizard
are the next 40 years
of net worth individuals holy grail,
the end.
And that's, and...
So what am I looking for?
With, you know,
I'm looking for a no--.
I mean, look, I've, I've
alluded to it enough.
I'm extremely bullish on crypto punks
because I think it's OG, OG.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- I think it's 8-bit culture.
I think people underestimate
the visual attachment
to 40 and 50 year olds
that have wealth.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- And I think that there's only,
I think 10,000, with, you know,
and so like, that's, that's,
that's a good starting point.
Like it's established DRC.
Like it basically became,
kind of like, the thing
that everyone pointed
to and built on top of.
- Absolutely, they basically,
were the reason the ERC 721 token...
- Was created.
- was created, it's for them.
- Just think about that,
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Right? And then--,
- Culturally significant,
technologically significant.
- Enough people give a shit about it,
there's only a certain amount.
It's got all the things
that make you realize,
like, they built it in a way...
they're two very nice men.
I think that matters, you know,
like, they're part of the community.
And I think, they built it in a way
that people care.
Like, they care about a purple hat.
Like literally, I care about purple hats
because actually,
because of the hat I'm wearing,
I own the eSports team called version one
with the owners of the Minnesota Vikings,
- [Eric] Yeah.
- and like, we wear purple hats.
like, it's just like, I don't know,
like, it's not super complicated,
and like the earrings and the VR, like...
So, I'm trying to find things,
like that hash mass,
that's something I haven't dug into.
- [Eric] Yeah.
- But the cryptic nature
of the things you can't see and
clearly...
- Interesting.
That's interesting.
- Correct, it's interesting.
And then look, I do think
that there'll be things
that come along, like,
that I've been around,
Pokemon's official, official NFT,
official, official NFT project,
is going to matter.
- Sure, yeah.
Classic IP coming in will always have a...
have a place in our hearts
- A hundred percent and new IP,
like the next Star Wars,
Pokemons, you know,
and Star Treks are going to be built,
starting with NFT.
- [Eric] Yeah, I know that.
I know that we're at the half hour.
If you've got one more minute...
- One more minute I could push to 12:03,
so, I got that minute, go.
- Yeah, cool.
So, I dunno if you noticed,
but, I started a project
called unofficial punks,
which was like this social community.
And really, what I want
to tell you about it is,
it's exciting to me to see people who are,
have been priced out of buying a punk,
who can now still participate,
and that's the community aspect
- [Gary] A hundred percent.
- that I really,
really like to push and share.
- You know what's cool
about that right, Eric?
- [Eric] Yeah.
- it's the counterculture,
right?
Hunks were authentic,
then they became too big, then you...
You know how I see that?
Like rock and roll.
The rolling stones were super authentic,
- [Eric] Yeah.
- their concerts got expensive,
here comes the clash.
- Yes.
- Right? And that's what I--,
And I think that's amazing,
and by the way, they both co-exist.
I hate the people want
everything to be or.
- Right, there's a, there's an "and"
in this space for everything, yeah.
- I think the word "and",
if this space can fall in
love with the word "and".
I think that you'll see
a lot more happiness
and I'm hoping to be a champion
of that word in this space.
- Yeah, well, thank you
so much for joining me.
- Eric, thank you so much brother.
I wish you well.
YouTube watcher, what's up it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super well,
during these times.
I also want to ask you, please subscribe,
because my commitment
and exploration of YouTube
is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it,
and I hope I see you soon.